alors le froid aujourd'hui ramène à
chaque fois cette question des sans abri
est ce qu'on est bien équipée est ce que
le politique fasse son travail anie
samson luc ferrandez sont avec nous
encore cette année pour le panel
municipal bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir
bonne année au soir bonne année un
itinérant qui est mort à notre dame de
grâce hier je fais écouter madame
pelambres d'abord que 10 dans le cas de
cet homme qui ne voulait pas aller vers
un abri 1 2 qu'il y avait assez d'abris
le problème on va l'écouter encore là
comme les hôpitaux c'est la main
d'oeuvre on est con s'il doit y avoir
d'autres lieux encore une fois ce n'est
pas ça le problème la ville de mort est
la capacité on a baby ont le nez plein
milieu compte utiliser je tiens à ribéry
le groupe d'anjou en ce moment c'est le
personnel qualifié parce qu'on a annoncé
plus tôt que on va prendre un stade donc
pour pour créer un abri on avoue vers
les stations de métro hier annie est ce
qu'on fait bien fasse encore une fois à
ces situations là quand ali zari ben moi
je trouve que c'est encore un peu de
l'improvisation n'est fait la même chose
l'année dernière on en voit le stade de
soccer qui étaient encore vides on
aurait pu l'ouvrir depuis les mesures
d'urgence qui est que lévis le
renouveler en décembre janvier lors le
fait aujourd'hui fait moins 28 quand
est-ce qu'ils vont être ouverts sa voix
est ouvert ce week-end c'est un peu tard
on sait qu'à chaque année on a un
problème pour loger nous est inhérent de
plus en plus parce qu'il y en a de plus
en plus et on attend encore à la
dernière minute pour le faire pourtant
c'est écrit en lice ils arrivent à s'en
vient on sait qu'il fait froid je pense
que c'est une mauvaise planification
parce qu'on est en mesure d'urgence en
mesure d'urgence on peut tout faire mail
actuellement on est pris notre temps où
on fait un peu d'improvisation lui que
moi aussi je partage le même avis le jeu
comprend pas c'était prévisible c'était
annoncé je sais qu'il ya deux quartiers
qui ont annoncé des ouvertures de petits
centres j'avais l'impression que les 60
malraux des
budgétaire j'ai trouvé cela l'un est pas
mais efficace et oui oui ceci étant dit
c'est c'est pas la base du problème la
base problème bon cette personne là le
froid à chaque année il va y avoir des
mots des morts parce que des personnes
qu'ils ne veulent pas être dirigés vers
les abris c'est normal ça arrive le
problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas de place
dans les abris lors d'une situation
particulière avec l'aco vide mais mais
si on avait ce n'est pas que la question
de la coved à ses yeux une augmentation
du nombre d'itinérants et maintenant on
l'est on essaie de les traiter avec plus
de professionnalisme des groupes qui
traite les itinérants que ce soit la
maison du père mission
portes ouvertes etc ils ont une approche
80 dorénavant d'aller plus loin que
juste donner de la soupe puis un café et
puis point de chaleur la proche de
psycho social de la recherche de
logement de la santé urbaine santé
mentale ça c'est beaucoup
professionnalisé dans les dernières
années bon mais il faut tenir compte
juste une petite chance je sais qu'on en
a beaucoup de sujets mais il faut tenir
compte que c'est pas juste ouvrir un
abri la nuit qui va les aider il faut
aussi qu'à être capable les logis le
jour s'occuper d'eux le jour
l'actionnant en oeuvre des abris
temporaires rapide mais le jour les gens
doivent être aussi au chaud doivent être
la même chose le mais c'est pas mal mal
prêt est très mal planifiée pour
l'instant et le plan d'action qui était
accepté l'année passée au point de 1.4
millions auprès de tous les partenaires
a pas encore été mis en place très bien
les postes de quartier monsieur caron la
police de montréal 10 avez-vous c'est ça
fait son temps il ya trente pas de
quartier à notre eau il n'y a pas
d'autres villes on a l'impression que le
pendule vodden moi j'ai couvert la
police communautaire des années 80 c'est
la grande mode procès longueuil découvre
ça aujourd'hui bon bref on va entendre
madame plan sur cette idée de couper des
postes de police à montréal
voit ça d'un bon oeil qu'on réfléchisse
au spvm à notre service de police qui
est très important près de montréal
surtout dans le contexte actuel de
l'augmentation malheureuse du nombre
d'événements des armes à feu
ça peut sembler contre intuitif de dire
qu'on va couper les poches pour être
plus sécuritaire comment voyez ce n'est
moi j'ai écouté la conférence parce que
monsieur caron a dit à la commission des
finances en disant il faut absolument
qu'on transforme le système parce que ça
nous coûte 200 quand policiers de plus
est ce que c'est les mêmes 250 politique
madame madame plante s'est engagé à
financer qu'elles financent plus parce
que je trouve que les moyens c'est
vraiment gros moi j'étais là quand la
police de quartier a commencé en 1994
pourquoi installer parce que l'ancien
système dans lequel monsieur car on veut
revenir et une police dépersonnaliser
non responsable d'un quartier est ce que
koffi la police de quartier je vous en
parle avec passion parce que ça a été
mon grand débat depuis les 25 dernières
années ça a été de pouvoir ramener la
police près des citoyens comme on est
capable mieux servir le citoyen pour
commander cas pas mieux servir le
policier lui dit annie lui dit oui mais
je vais couper du bois celui voir plus
de policiers partout sur le territoire
on croyait pas son nom mais la police de
quartier à faire en sorte que les
policiers sont responsables de leur
quartier connaissent les citoyens et les
citoyens connaissent les gens
connaissent les problématiques travail
avec le milieu communautaire lorsqu'on
va faire ce qu'on va mettre des
policiers qui vont patrouiller un peu
partout sans connaître la réalité locale
avec les problématiques avec les
assureurs c'est une grave erreur
il ya quelques mois on disait que le
modèle de police de quartier est
excellent
longueuil faisait les manchettes en
disant on va aller parler aux gens avant
qu'un problème et ça c'est de la police
de quartier dans mon quartier - u2 plus
en plus de police à pied de police à
vélo et ç'a un impact important auprès
des étudiants ils les connaissent il
leur parle pas juste c'est inhérent les
commerçants aussi rond dans les
commerces lors de leur demande leur
sentiment général etc se font donner des
informations ça fonctionne très bien
est-ce qu'on peut encore se la payer
parce que ce que monsieur caron disait
est quand même important de d'abord là
le nombre d'heures travaillées diminue
parce que on a une nouvelle réalité il
ya 10 de plus en plus de femmes donc du
congé de maternité aussi des congés de
paternité congés parentaux il ya aussi
de la formation continue parce qu'on ne
traite plus comme avant alors amants ce
point des tireurs pour le mettre dans la
voiture ou d'une contravention comment
ça se fait plus il ya d'information
continue aussi sur le racisme donc il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'heures
disponibles qui ont disparu et en même
temps des problématiques qui a longtemps
augmenté et qu'ils ont augmenté
énormément alors dans les rapports
l'administration ont le don le beaucoup
vu les fusillades des armes à feu le le
la fraude les agressions sexuelles la
violence jette on peut pas tout faire
cesser tous de la formation ok mais on
peut pas tout jeter à l'eau comme ça
très bien on va juste un débat parce que
c'est pas fini même jeu car on était
assez clair il a lancé la discussion
minutes 30 secondes chacun taxer les
non-vaccinés chercheurs de votre cas
mais
taxer les noms parce qu'on parle des
gens vulnérables ça peut toucher des
gens vulnérables ou si annie qu'en
pensez vous moi je pense qu'il faut
trouver une façon de pouvoir pénaliser
ceux qui sont non vaccinés pour l'impact
que ces leçons notre système de santé
actuel c'est pas juste eux c'est sait
l'impact que e.on sur l'ensemble du
système qui est rendue fragile si c'est
pas une taxe que ce soit à relever
lorsqu'ils vont se présenter à l'hôpital
ou s'il décide de pau faire le vaccin
doit pas prendre le vaccin qui nous
signe qui sait une entente en disant je
refuse les vaccins et les soins qui vont
suivre aussi je sais il faut il faut
quand même une éducation parce que c'est
l'impact à 90% de la population le lirez
chose de satisfaisant le devoir qui
aurait put passe droit mais moi je suis
contre cette mesure je pense qu'il faut
aller vers la vaccination obligatoire
c'est plus simple et ça ne discrimine
pas une personne qui par exemple légère
déficience intellectuelle
sur le seuil de pauvreté ou au dessous
du seuil de pauvreté que le conte lui
donne on est devant une contribution par
c est l hôpital en plus ça peut pas être
une solution les détails ça peut être
compliqué dans l'exécution de tout ça
merci beaucoup à vous deux bonnes années
et à très bientôt au revoir et à bientôt